il ya beaucoup de coraux qui sont morts
c'était un récit de superbes il ya
seulement trois ans en 2010 à cause du
changement climatique
la température aux maldives a
brutalement augmenté de 4 degrés pendant
plusieurs mois
conséquence une grande partie des coraux
n'a pas résisté à la chaleur alors
plusieurs fois par an thomas et son
équipe plonge au fond de la mer pour
observer l'évolution du récif
[Musique]
le corail c'est ça cela ressemble un
petit arbre mais c'est en fait un animal
marin qui vit en colonie autour des îles
ils forment ce que l'on appelle la
barrière de corail sous l'eau thomas
découvre un véritable cimetière de
coraux on reconnaît un corail mort à sa
couleur blanchâtre et à son extrême
fragilité
la plupart d'entre eux n'auraient pas
supporté le réchauffement climatique
plutôt mort vraiment complètement morte
juste une toute petite toute petite
branche qui résiste cela peut paraître
anodin mais la barrière de corail est
vitale pour les maldives
elle permet de casser les vagues et
protège les îles de la montée des eaux
là sur le récif convient de voir je
dirais peut-être 10% de vivans voici les
conséquences directes de la mort des
coraux
thomas nous emmène sur l'île vierge
située juste en face et qui est censé
être protégé par le récif en seulement
trois ans elle a été totalement rongé
par la mer ici c'est très net
ça c'était le niveau de l'île ces arbres
étaient sur l'île maintenant les vagues
sont arrivées ont fait éroder le sable
les armes sont tombés avec la montée des
eaux
cette île paradisiaque s'est peu à peu
transformée en champ de ruines
aux maldives l'eau monte d'environ 2 cm
par an c'est pas un petit arbre c'était
sur le terrain sinon il n'aurait jamais
poussé je pense qu'on a perdu
déjà 50 mètres l'un d'eux puis deux puis
trois ans donc si ça continue comme ça
il est possible que dans 20 ans comme
elle c'est tout l'archipel qui
pourraient disparaître d'ici 2050 alors
en 2009
le gouvernement des maldives a décidé de
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé pour alerter
la communauté internationale sont les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
le président a eu l'idée un peu folle
d'organiser un conseil des ministres
sous l'eau un coup de communication
histoire de rappeler que son pays était
en train de couler ça n'arrête non
dans les resorts la situation est prise
très au sérieux car si les il venait à
disparaître ce serait également les
dizaines de millions de dollars
d'investissements qui risquerait de
prendre l'eau alors pour lutter contre
l'érosion
les responsables d'hôtels ont
littéralement barricadé leurs îles sur
celle où séjournent virginie et nicolas
des blocs de béton ont été installés
pour casser les vagues éviter qu'elle ne
ronge la plage et comme cela n'est pas
suffisant
d'autres sont obligés de réensabler
lille plusieurs fois par an mais ici
l'érosion est un sujet tabou
arthur le manager de l'établissement
balaie d'un revers de main l'hypothèse
de la disparition des maldives ce n'est
pas un problème d'érosion
j'entends beaucoup de gens qui disent
que les maldives auront coulé dans 10 15
ans voire même 20 ans mais franchement
vous pensez que je serai ici si je
pensais vraiment que le pays allait
disparaître une explication très
personnelle bien éloignée de celle des
spécialistes
[Musique]